uh let's talk a little bit about
surveillance facial recognition
technology and a company that's
attempting to fight back against it
facial recognition software is becoming
more and more common amazon has a
physical shop where they scan faces when
people come in facebook searches photos
of users to figure out where you might
want to tag certain people and of course
the counterpoint to that technology is
privacy concerns and the privacy
concerns i don't think i have to
enumerate them for you one by one but
generally speaking we have an
understanding of how this type of
technology could be used to really
violate the privacy of the average
person there's a company called hyper
face not hyperspace hyper face and what
their latest project involves is
printing patterns on clothing or
textiles which appear to sort of have
eyes mouths and other features which the
goal is would be interpreted as a face
by computer facial recognition systems
Adam Harvey is the berlin-based artist
and technologists who wants to overwhelm
and confuse facial recognition systems
by present presenting them with a ton of
false hits so they can't tell what's
actually a face and what's just
someone's clothing and he had a previous
project called CV dazzle where he
attempted to create uh makeup and
hairstyling that would cause the facial
recognition systems not to work too well
unclear how well that worked but now the
idea is these patterns that you can
print on clothes and if you blanket an
area if enough people are wearing them
the idea is facial recognition
technology would effectively become
totally useless it wouldn't be able to
identify who's there what's a face and
what isn't this reminds me of a scanner
darkly which is uh both a book and it
will was really turn into a movie but
but the book is by philip k dick where
they're these full-body cloaks that
constantly show different faces and
bodies to confuse these types of systems
sort of reminds me of that type of thing
i don't know if you've seen the movie or
read the book i have not but you have to
wonder if these facial recognition
software will get even more advanced to
counter this yeah it's kind of like when
there's a torrent site the government
shuts it down and these people come out
with something newer and better or uh
adblock in websites going back and forth
is gonna be some kind of arms race for
this yeah it's going to create a sort of
technological arms race where the facial
recognition systems will probably just
be made even better so I I so sort of
understand the idea here uh how much do
you worry about this I mean how how far
do when you're walking around especially
in cities like Boston when I was in
London over the vacation there cameras
everywhere yeah I don't seem to mind it
myself I know a lot of people get super
sensitive over their own privacy but I'm
just the opinion that if you're
especially in a public place then you've
you've kind of given up your right to
privacy in that game nah I don't some
people subscribe to the view of if
you're not doing anything wrong then you
don't have to worry I don't ascribe to
that I'll see I don't I don't I don't
buy into that at all that resonates with
you I understand the position that
they're coming from even if I don't
agree with it for me that's one of the
ways in which we turn away from systemic
problems until they personally affect us
and and I don't think that that's that's
a good way to go that we we would allow
a lot of violations of privacy really
for no good justified reason because we
say hey if I'm not doing anything wrong
I don't care for me the if you're out in
public then you're sort of but accepting
that you might be filmed is a much
better argument for me and I know that
this is sort of more of a practical
reality because of smartphone technology
I'm sure that as I was walking around
museums in London last week and people
were taking pictures of different
exhibits or of their friends are selfies
of themselves I'm probably in a bunch of
people's pictures in the background and
it's just sort of a reality based on the
technology that we have but still if I'm
out in public if i'm in downtown
crossing boston were washington street
intersects whatever street that is where
you come out of the subway downtown
crossing but there's cameras everywhere
and if I'm walking around there III
don't really have any good justification
to say there cannot be any camera I
can't appear anywhere or be seen I'm out
in public in a very very crowded area
this is totally different in my mind Pat
I don't know about you then warrantless
bulk NSA surveillance for
example or someone monitoring my text
messages i think that walking around in
public is not the same thing everybody
has a different line that they draw
though and i don't know exactly where my
line is I'm sort of building up a sense
of it uh I I do not believe though that
this type of technological solution it's
not really technology printing faces on
clothes I don't think this is going to
be what stops creeping surveillance I
think if it's going to stop it's going
to be some concerted effort to do it
legislatively yeah I think if you're
hyper sensitive to your own privacy at
this point this day and age with cameras
being everywhere you kinda have to go
off the grid and I think that's the
expectation of you and I'm not willing
to do that I don't know about you I I
have I have a cousin I found out
recently who is living very much off the
grid in Argentina and I'm talking about
no plumbing I'm talking about you know
some electricity but barely any and part
of it is sort of just getting away from
the the mainstream culture of technology
and corporatism and surveillance
etcetera I have my critiques but I'm not
ready to do that well I don't think it's
surprising that two people on a show
have a low standard for you know the
image they put out there yeah no I don't
say on the bonus show today we are going
to talk about Leslie Jones saying that
the publishing of Milo in opelousas book
spreads hate we're going to talk about
that we will talk about Ivanka and jared
kushner finding their DC home you will
be thrilled no and also mattel is making
an Amazon Alexa for kids and I want to
discuss whether this is uh an
interesting and good idea or a way to
suck children into brand loyalty very
early or maybe a combination of both
those stories on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership i voted 17
is the coupon code if you want a
discount off of membership thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the david pakman show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated